- [Chase] Where you at.
- Yeah okay, then let's
get right into this
because we're up against a tough time.
- [Chase] Okay, cool.
- Good? What number?
- [Man] 327.
- Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
episode 327 of the #AskGaryVee
Show and I'm excited.
Actually Chase, I think after we do this
you've got to be in the top three of
doing content with another human being.
There are now at least four, five,
six jam sessions that we've had--
- [Chase] It's true.
- Which i think speaks to our kinship.
I'm really excited to have
Chase Jarvis on the show.
He has a new book coming out.
I really feel like I'm becoming
the new kind of like Today Show.
(Chase laughing)
I got hit up three times today by people
who I had really great like acquaintances,
subtle relationships with back
in early Twitter 09, 10, 11.
I think the word has
gotten on the street that
being on this podcast
sells a shit load of books
so that makes me happy.
Chase has a new book. he's a friend.
he's an entrepreneur, he's a creative,
a creator, but what have I left out Chase
for the people who don't know who you are?
- No, you're crushing it.
Just lifelong photographer,
probably left photography
into starting CreativeLIVE,
Greylock back company.
10 years in in the biz
and we got more than
10 million people using the platform.
It's a place to go to learn
creativity entrepreneurship,
from the world's top
experts people like Branson,
Tim Ferriss, Brene Brown,
friends of ours, yeah.
- I remember when you and I did a event
at the Javits Center,
which i think is like
a famous iconic photography event, right?
- [Chase] Yeah, yeah.
- What was the name of it
again, do you remember?
- [Chase] PhotoPlus Expo.
- Right, so I just
remember I loved that talk
that we did together because
it was in your domain
and just watching the admiration
from so many people there for you,
it helped me remember,
a lot of times I go into the wine world.
My sister just went on a
trip to Napa with her husband
and Justin, my homie, who works here,
and they went with friends
and their friends were taken aback by
how people reacted to me,
because that was my world
and that's the comp that I'm giving,
which is it was awesome
to see the admiration
in that community for you.
I mean really that is where you,
that's your origin story, right?
- Yeah, that's my OG story.
And basically I did for photography
what you did for wine,
was help people understand
that the Internet was gonna
change everything and that--
- Did you get a lot of, I apologize,
did you get a lot of pushback
in your earliest days of
saying this is gonna be big?
Caleb were you a fan,
like you're really in
this one, like tell me.
- [Caleb] Yeah, I watched
your video of the ski trip
where you did the burst images--
- Oh yeah, this was the first
time that I have on record
and I've scoured the Internet where people
were paying me behind the
scenes to create on social,
the campaign was actually secondary.
So they were taking access
to me and my audience,
which I filtered very carefully.
I will only connect brands to my audience
if there was a real connection.
So some of the photography,
I did the first ever
campaign for the camera
that now all of these cameras shoot video,
the very first one was the D90
and I basically made a
video with that camera
about the campaign for that camera
and it sold more cameras than
that could have ever sold.
- Without knowing anything,
another good friend of mine
and so I don't even want
to go there too long,
but like in a lot of ways has a lot of
nuances to Casey, right?
- [Chase] Yeah, super.
- Right, like when I think
about him coming from
a movie kind of thing
like and then you know,
but there's some, right?
- [Chase] They're super, super similar.
- There's some crossover there.
Do you guys know each other?
- Oh yeah, oh yeah, super, super well.
Super well is a stretch,
we know each other.
He's got me on his Boosted boards
and all the stuff that Casey does,
tries to risk our lives, but I think--
- Is Casey off the grid right now?
- [Chase] He's pretty
quiet in LA right now.
- I mean I know what the plan was,
but like I don't know
what the execution's been.
I see Jus going.
(people speaking off mic)
What's that?
Right, where he talked about
a bunch of stuff, right?
That one really well, right?
It got referenced, he talk about Beme,
because I think somebody referenced it.
Yeah, somebody referenced it.
- [Woman] He did talk
about going off the Grid.
- [Chase] Yeah, he's being
quiet for a little bit.
And I think you know
you highlight something
pretty interesting, which is
were people throwing rocks
when you were sort of trying to reinvent
the photography industry
and the answer is yeah,
but I wanna be too too dramatic,
but I literally had death threats.
Like you're taking money
out of my family's income
and you're putting it on the tables
and in the pockets of photographers
who don't know what they're
doing but you're giving--
- I got them today because people
don't think you should do work for free
and I still will never understand that.
(Chase laughing)
- [Chase] Totally.
- I will never to the, today
death threats, right now.
- That's I mean, what is Bezos says?
You have to be willing to be misunderstood
for long periods of time and then voila,
someday you're right and--
- [Gary] That's my entire
framework of my life.
- Same.
- It's all I believe in the same in.
- Same and the same was true
with photography early on
then I leverage that into oh no,
learning online actually gonna be a thing.
- Let's make a hard picture pivot
because I've been learning
from interviewing lately
my strengths and weaknesses.
Let's go right hardcore into the book,
like what's the book
about, why'd you write it?
- Sure, the book's about three things.
One, every person is creative.
I'm trying to rewrite the narrative
that art is not creativity.
Creativity is building businesses,
writing code, building a family,
basically everything that we do,
we as humans are creating machines.
It's the foundation the differentiates us
from every other species.
- [Gary] Can I jump in because I love to?
- Yes.
Has anyone ever said no?
(laughing)
- Usually I don't ask
and everybody who's watching gets upset,
so I'm trying to not be as hated.
My team, Ryan Harwood,
when I bought PureWow, we
started Gallery Media Group.
DRock, Andy, subtleties
from this collective team.
I only in the last year
and a half have decided
that I was super creative.
- [Chase] Yep, but see this is my point--
- I couldn't make that connection,
which is why it's powerful
what you're saying.
I lived it.
I was so entrenched to I'm a businessman.
I did along the way in the last decade
say I'm creative in that.
Now I just think I'm uber creative
and actually super creative.
- Yeah, but saying you're
creative in something,
like just take the "in
something" out of it.
- Actually I think I'm the
greatest creative person.
- [Chase] It does not
surprise me that you say that.
- I actually genuinely
think I'm in the process,
DRock I'm in the process.
I will win an Academy Award
and I'm gonna say fuck you
do you DRock, I told you.
Go ahead Chase.
- So you were the perfect
case study, right?
That you were like I'm
this and then over time
you realize no wait, this is creativity.
- And right now a
stay-at-home dad, a lawyer,
a concrete manufacturer
doesn't think they are,
but your point is they are
and I'm actually buying that
today and I don't know if I
would have seven years ago.
- For sure and that's
why I'm trying to rewrite
the culture narrative about creativity.
So that's thing one, everyone's creative
and I'm gonna rewrite the narrative.
Thing two is that creativity is a muscle.
Maya Angelou's like the, it's
like the infinite resource,
the more you use the more you have.
This is not surprising
and muscles like anything,
the more you use it stronger you get.
- [Gary] 100%.
- I'm trying to get people to acknowledge
that creativity in point
one and then flex it.
And then thing three--
- [Gary] This is so--
- Let me get the me--
- [Gary] Please, I'm sorry, I apologize.
- No, no, it's good thing three is that
it's in creating in small daily
ways and acknowledging that,
all the things that you just talked about,
and creating everyday, making,
that you actually realize
and you have agency
over creating your life.
It's just creativity on a different scale.
- I got it.
Brother, I'm a buyer.
I tried to jump in on
number two for one reason,
'cause you motivated me, inspired me,
like I'm trying to get people to practice
reframing their perspective.
- [Chase] Bingo.
- I've come to realize and it's so intense
like you can't even feel,
like only now am I
tapping into feeling it.
I'm like oh, I practice
gratitude every day.
You know that whole thing,
I make pretend my kids and mom died,
that whole thing, that's
me practicing perspective--
- Subtitle here, established
a daily practice,
infuse your world with meaning,
and succeed in work and life.
In work and life.
- [Gary] By the way you're
selling books right now.
- Good.
- Because I'm telling you right
now my audience is making,
I can feel it, I can feel
the people right now on live
making the connection point
to a lot of the principles
that probably subconsciously
make them interested
in what I'm talking about
and this is a version
or a lane within it that I
think and you know what's funny?
A lot of people struggle,
you know I've met with a
bunch of employees this week.
A lot of them struggle with,
they are doing a tangible thing,
but they all like I'm creative,
but then it feels like that's fluffy.
- [Chase] Dude yeah,
let me talk about that.
- Just like strategic.
- They think it's that
we've been sold a narrative
that it's fluffy and it's
naive to follow your calling
and that if you are if
you identify as a creative
it's a nice to have, let
me tell you something.
Every person that you look up to, admire,
whether it's you or Richard
Branson or Brene Brown
or your neighbor who lives
in integrity and is a badass.
Every single one of
those lives was created.
All of those people understand that
they are creative naturally
and they put that to use
and so if you're wondering
what the disconnect is
between what you're doing
and what they're doing,
first thing is they have
acknowledged their creative.
Second is they're putting
that to use everyday
and they are using that
muscle to create their life.
- Third, they've practiced to embrace no.
- [Chase] Yeah, of course
you've gotta say no--
- Like to me this is like the underpinning
in the hard wiring to
creativity is the courage
and lack of fear and
ability to quantify judgment
that if you're not capable
of, you're not going anywhere.
- I talk a lot about that
in the book is intuition.
So we've been also, we've
been sold a lot of lies
and there's no evil genius over
here telling us to do this,
but the reality is culture
wants us to be average
because it's predictable, your parents,
they want you to be safe.
- [Gary] Can we play on
this for a second Chase?
- Your career counselor,
they all want you to do the
middle and I'm telling you this,
the riskiest thing in
the whole world to do is
what everybody else wants you to do.
- Chase, what's really
interesting about this is
it's actually, when you say that
my brain went into a place of
negativity is louder than positivity.
This is playing out in real data,
yet more people are happy than ever.
They don't fully realize,
like there's so much
interesting stuff going on
when it comes to this.
There is no evil genius, school's fucked.
- [Chase] Totally.
- Like that absolute, like it's too rigid.
It's just too rigid.
Actually, you know what?
Schools awesome for 33% of people.
It actually means that there needs to be,
what we don't have in
school in modern times is
the heavy alternative for kids like us.
- For sure, that's why
I created CreativeLive.
Honestly, literally because there's no--
- [Gary] There's no alternative.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] There's no scale alternative.
- Right and the reality--
- There's homeschooling.
- [Chase] For sure.
- There's creative rogue parents,
but there's no macro system in place.
- Agree and also if our
parents had one job,
we'll have five, the next generation is
gonna have five at the same time
and so you better be
able to acquire skills
and again, all of this you just,
you can call it personal
development, fulfillment, whatever.
I'm couching it in creativity.
You are in charge, you have agency
over what you do with your life.
- [Gary] Are you TikToking it?
- [Chase] No.
- Please do, you'll be great at it.
- Damn I knew he was gonna say that.
- [Gary] You knew you're
walking into that buzzsaw?
You should have fucking downloaded
the app yesterday and been prepared.
- [Chase] I know, I know, I saw from it-
- You got busy.
You saw it from a mile away.
- I'm walking up
like aw shit, I don't have TikTok.
- You're gonna crush on it.
It's gonna work for you.
- I appreciate it.
- You have a real message.
A lot of my friends and
we do this to each other,
they'll say things like,
"You really sound clarified this time."
Like we're all doing the
same thing, the creative.
The people that are doing,
sometimes it's hazy,
sometimes it's clear,
sometimes it's right?
Like I'm feeling so pumped right now
because this is a very,
maybe it's our hypothesis are
matching at a current moment,
you feel clear as fuck to me right now.
- Crystal, because it's
been a long time coming.
The books been in my
brain for like nine years
and I've been working on two years.
(phone ringing)
- [Gary] You've had other the photo books.
- All photo books before, two photo books.
This is my first like OG doing it right.
- This is your fucking, what, sorry?
- [Man] And.
(phone ringing)
- And?
- [Man] That's how it's spelled.
- Anad?
- [Anad] Hello, yes?
- [Anad] Yes, speaking.
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk and
you're on with Chase Jarvis.
- Hi man, what's up?
- [Anad] Oh wow, that's amazing.
- Don't lose your mind,
we're gonna get through this.
(laughing)
We're gonna get through
this, what's your question?
- Do you have a question my friend?
- [Anad] Yeah, I have a question.
So my question is I'm a
relatively new creator,
so can I give you a little
bit of my background
before I, just for context?
- Please.
- [Anad] So, sorry.
Yeah, so I'm a marketer.
I've been working in
marketing as a corporate job
for the last seven years,
but I recently quit my job
and was able to go full-time
with my own video marketing
agency where I help people create content
for YouTube and Instagram
specifically and IGTV.
- [Chase] Nice job.
- Smart.
- [Anad] Thank you so
I'm a new entrepreneur,
but I'm also a very creative person.
So growing up I would
always consider myself
to be a very creative person
and creating content is like my outlet
so I have my own very
small YouTube channel
where I create content, but my dilemma is
I know Gary talks about
how document, don't create.
But then as a marketer I'm thinking
I need to make content that people
are searching for, doing the SEO and--
- That's because you're
confusing marketing with sales.
A marketer, she or he is
building for the long term.
Your explanation as a marketer
was tangible and transactional.
- [Anad] Mm-hmm.
Could you elaborate on that?
- I sure can.
- [Chase] How much time
you got? (laughing)
- You're using the term
marketer in a modern world
where we have in a lot of ways over leaned
into tactics and short term ROIs.
You're trying to hack the
tangible search queries
to create short term views
or macro/micro very quick,
micro, not macro, micro transactional.
What you're doing is
transacting and selling,
which is being confused as
actual brand building and marketing.
You're not gonna struggle
with where you were going
with this question once
you understood that
branding and marketing is a marathon,
but right now in digital marketing
a lot of people have
made it transactional.
I've never, this is why I'm bad,
this is why I'm not as big,
only recently have we
even started somewhat
trying to get good at like search or SEO.
I've been on YouTube since the get
and still have no concept of titles
and thumbnails for marketing.
I'm going so brand and marketing
of continuous message at scale.
- Yeah, I'd say if you're
gonna prioritize something
you gotta know who you
are and what you're making
and for whom and why.
The other stuff takes
care of itself over time,
but if you do the other
stuff first, it's backwards.
It's like you're gonna go be a banker
because your parents told you so.
You need to look at what do you want to do
and the market, all the little SEO,
all those little nuts
and bolts, it's great.
If you're literally living your
life by the data exclusively
then you're gonna look
like everybody else.
You're gonna be fighting
for the same search terms
and how are you gonna stand out?
The only way you can actually stand out is
by being unapologetically,
no-questions-asked you.
- And my friend, Anad,
what ended up happening is
it even blended into the creative.
The reason people continue
to post the same photos
of their TNA or of their abs
or a beautiful place they went in to
is they know that the
likes are gonna be there
and it's limited the creativity
on the creativity part.
Not even on the quant, it
started in digital marketing
on the titles, the math,
but it's subconsciously
has blended into the art
itself where people right now
are posting on Instagram things
they have no passion about,
but they know it will do well--
- Quote, do well, 'cause
do well is a very--
- Correct, but do well
to the way he framed up
his first two things out of his mouth.
- [Chase] 100%, 100%.
- Those don't come out of
my mouth as a marketer.
- Which is interesting
if they take likes away,
the world's gonna get a
hell of a lot more creative.
- [Gary] I'm pushing.
- It's gonna blow up.
- And lemme rephrase,
I'm pushing something
that I didn't think of.
Kudos to them to testing it
in Australian and Canada.
I got wind of that I'm
like this is fucking,
I was on the make new shit
but I was trying to
encourage people to be brave.
Instagram's doing it for you.
Everyone's mad at the algorithm.
They're starting to learn how
the algorithm actually works.
They watch human behavior.
By the way, Instagram's
taking away the likes,
not for their health, they're doing it
because they observed
in data what I observed
as what I do for a living that people
were starting to limit creativity.
Anad, do you understand, go ahead.
- Yeah, no Anad do you feel like
you're understanding what
we're putting down here?
You feel like you're getting
your question answered?
- [Anad] I am, yeah definitely.
I think it's a struggle between,
there's a conflict between
this is what I want
to put out into the world,
I want to share my journey,
which is I'm a marketer
and new entrepreneur
and I was able to quit my
nine-to-five job finally
after working on the side
hustle for the last five years.
- I love that.
- [Anad] And now I want to
show people how I did it.
- Yep, that's your ticket right there man,
because you know what, that's your story.
Unapologetically, no questions asked.
- [Gary] Period, couldn't
be a bigger buyer.
- If you're trying to
talk about marketing,
there's a bazillion people
talking about marketing.
There's only one you, you've got your DNA,
you have your experience,
that's the only way you
can stand out my man.
You cannot stand out and
fit in at the same time
and you're only gonna
get there by being you.
- Anad, what I would tell you is
this is why I push patience so much.
There'd be absolutely no conflict
if you actually were willing to wait.
- [Chase] Do you.
- Does that make sense Anad?
Do you see where I'm going with that?
There's a conflict when you're looking for
a short term ROI on vanity metrics.
- [Anad] That's right.
- I know.
(Chase laughing)
- No, no, I'm really proud of you.
I like the way this is going,
you see where I'm going?
What people people may not understand yet
about what I'm doing is the reason
I have seven to 11 things I'm standing on
is you need them all,
you need all those ingredients
to properly cook the meal.
The second you take away
patience and you buy into
everything else I'm
saying, you're vulnerable.
The second you take away work ethic
because you don't think hustle's
cool anymore, you're vulnerable.
The second you take away
empathy, you're vulnerable.
What I'm putting down based on
what works for me and others
and I try to remind people
that as I observe them
is the ability to have
all the ingredients there,
because once you take one
out, the vulnerability comes.
Hearing you, who's been listening
and I can see what you're putting down,
by you quantifying what
we've just been talking about
and adding that patience
element, immediately,
immediately eliminates the
friction for short term metrics.
Why do you think I started
with 80,000 subscribers
on my YouTube channel
or whatever it was DRock
and I started three, four years ago, four?
Four years ago, five?
Five years ago even though
I was the OG of OGs there.
I went to Viddler, I never
paid attention to it.
I never asked for one time
on those thousand episodes
of Wine Library TV to subscribe.
I did nothing right,
'cause I was in it at
that point for 50 years.
- [Chase] You got this man, you got this.
- [Anad] So if I was to ask you,
you know my platform of choice is YouTube.
I just love the platform
and I feel like I can create
my best content on YouTube,
so what would you suggest?
I have like about 850
subscribers right now,
but I really wanna reach more people.
What would you suggest I do
in terms of how much content--
- How much content are you putting out?
- [Anad] Right now about
one to two videos a week.
- Let me ask you something,
have you heard the thing
fake it till you make it?
- I have, yeah I have heard.
- Okay, okay, just put
that shit on the shelf.
You need to make it
till you make it, okay?
You need to be putting content out there,
you need to be unapologetically you,
be making stuff every day
that is authentic to you,
that resonates with your audience,
and tells your story and
until you start doing that
you're gonna be stuck and
when you start doing that,
two things are gonna happen.
One, you're gonna have a bunch of energy
'cause you're gonna finally
be not doing what your mother,
your brother, your friends,
all these other people
are telling you to do.
And then two, the world's
gonna come help you
because they can sense that stuff,
they can smell it when you are doing you.
That's what G, when you just
like stepped on the scene,
boom, they're like this
guy no questions asked,
he's doing him and that is really sexy.
I mean sexy is like you know.
(woman laughing)
- No, no, you actually
mean it the actual way.
That was an attractive
man that hit the scene.
- Viddler, that dude is
an attractive man on Viddler in 2006.
- Listen Anad, I think
the biggest thing here is
you're gonna have to
get out of a framework
where your opening question starts with
"I have 850 subscribers and I want more",
that sentence is death.
It just is.
- [Chase] What story do you wanna tell?
- Listen to me.
I'm in a very interesting
zone post vacation,
I guess I could feel it
like a lot more angles.
I'm about to tell you something else.
Why do you think I put
document on a pedestal
and try to get you to make the ROI
the fact that your
grandkids are gonna see it,
is because I actually think
everything everyone's doing now,
when they're older, I predict
98% of the people on earth
that create content right now at scale,
which is everyone by
the way at some level,
that the best thing that happens from it,
this is now 98%, this
is a guess arbitrary,
but this is how I feel.
This is the number I'm putting on it.
That the best thing that happens
is not they quit their shitty
job and start a huge company.
It's not a viral moment.
It's not anything else then in 54 years
their granddaughter's gonna
come up to them and say,
"Nana, I'm just like you.
"In 2021 you said this and
that's how I think too."
That, that sentence because that's who
you're gonna be at 90.
That's what you're gonna
care about, your family.
And so the reason I try
to put that on pedestal
and get people to understand
how valuable that is,
is now all of a sudden Anad,
if that's why you're making content
what do you want your grand kids to see?
What do you want the
world to know about you?
Not hey, I mean I'm
obsessed with Mr. Beast.
I think he's so talented in understanding,
one of the few things that
does not come natural to me
because it doesn't have
day and day out community
and reading comics, it never was that,
it wasn't an app for the
first eight years, YouTube.
So I have so much respect for that,
but if you talk to somebody like that
it's still gonna be the story inside.
It can give you a little bit, brother,
any hack that gets you from
850 to 1,730 to 17,000,
it's a minor league move.
The thing that actually gets you there
is the fucking content.
- Totally and I'm gonna throw something.
You talk about "document, don't create"
and I'm gonna just put
a little twist on that,
because it's all creating
and why I believe,
and you tell me if I'm
putting words in your mouth
that you don't believe is that
what you're really
doing when you're saying
"document, don't create" is you're trying
to take the anxiety out of creating.
Because right now you're
going like oh, I need to--
- [Gary] 100%.
- I need to create
something really special--
- It is creating.
No, you got it, you nailed it.
You wanna hear the best part
of that whole little thing?
The only thing I consume is documentaries.
Not that that's exactly,
but it was funny when you said that.
That's exactly what, I'm
trying to eliminate--
- [Chase] The barrier.
- The barriers, which is what
caught me to the fluffy shit
that I'm not necessarily all, listen.
- Totally, but that's what
I'm trying to do here is
I'm trying to take the
barriers away from creating
and I'm saying you have
this engine inside of you.
Right now you're trying to say,
you're trying to calculate.
Stop calculating, the
shit's not out there,
it's in here man and you've got it.
I just want you to start doing the thing--
- [Gary] Math fucks you up.
- Yep.
- [Anad] Yeah.
- [Chase] Yeah. (laughing)
- [Anad] I can definitely
say I'm very paralyzed
by just overthinking things
instead of just creating content--
- Because you're putting
metrics as the North Star.
Anybody who's putting
metrics, follow count, likes,
and data as the North Star are
inherently stuck creatively.
You over layer anxiety and
insecurity of judgment,
which is the comments and you're fucked,
which is why 99.99999% of
people are not winning yet.
- Here's another thing man,
I can tell just from how
you're asking, you want a map.
You want a dot, you are
here, you want dot, dot, dot,
and you want a red X
is where you're going.
You wanna be able to
see the whole picture.
I'm telling you've been
sold maps, they don't exist,
they're not real, all you
have is a compass brother.
You have a compass and that says
if you're listening to
what's actually in here,
this compass says go north
and as soon as you go north
that starts feeling right,
it starts feeling good,
because we don't have these maps.
We have intuition, we have what our soul
is telling us to do, who we are,
that's why he says "document, not create"
because that's about you
and that's what you need
to be doing right now,
not trying to follow someone else's math.
- And for everybody following along,
what Chase's analogy was awesome.
He's not talking about a compass
and holding it in your hand.
When he was saying that
I was like oh yeah?
I'm gonna throw the
fucking compass in the sea,
blindfold my fucking self
and walk through the fucking jungle.
And if you think a panther is
gonna get me, you're wrong.
- Because the compass is inside.
- 100%.
And I'll punch a fucking
panther in the face.
(Chase laughing)
- [Chase] Anad, you got that?
- Anad, punch panthers in
the face, hung up, next.
(Chase laughing)
And if you didn't follow that
analogy, here's what I mean.
There's always gonna be
big bad things in your way.
The reality is, is like I
don't know if the panther,
a panther probably killed you,
but I have always been
fascinated by the hacks.
You know one of the best memes
going on in culture right now?
Is people showing people
how things are made.
Like that cashew thing the
other day blew everyone's mind.
Blew my mind, I'm like,
that's what a fucking cashew looks like?
- [Chase] What, have I
been living under a rock?
I don't know you're talking about.
- Yeah, there was like there was a thing
that kind of went viral a couple days ago
that just showed pictures.
Do you know what cashews look
like when they're being grown?
They like come out of
this fucking apple thing,
I was like what the fuck?
Like there's a lot of this shit going on.
I've always been fascinated by
the things they tell you to do,
like aren't you supposed to,
are you supposed to punch 'em
or are you supposed to not?
What are the hacks for
like a bear or a lion,
there's all these weird hacks
right, don't move for a bear.
- [Chase] Oh, yeah one
you're supposed to play dead
then you're supposed to--
- Look, that's a cashew
Chase, look at this.
- Yeah, I did see that.
I didn't click on it, but
I was like okay, I get it.
(laughing)
(phone ringing)
- Synan, right?
That's fucking crazy.
Cashews are weird as shit.
- [Alex] Hello, this is Alex.
- Alec or Alex?
- [Man] Alex.
- Alex, what's up man, it's Gary V.
You're on with Chase Jarvis.
- Hey.
- [Alex] Hey Chase, I
had a question for you
about the creative muscle
because I heard you
talking with Tyler Babin.
- Yeah, creative muscle.
- Oh, fucking Babin.
- [Alex] I was wondering if
you should give that a break
or if you should just keep pushing harder?
- Well how do you build
muscles in real life, man?
- [Alex] Well you just keep going at it,
but they get sore, you know?
- Yeah they do get sore and
then what happens the next day,
you're a little bit stronger, right?
- [Alex] That's true.
- If you could live in I mean,
there's little bits of
rest, I get it, but--
- No, actually that's the right analogy.
Actually I think it's perfect.
I actually do think there's a lot of data
that says a rest day matters
and I think where you're going Alex
and where you're going Chase,
you're both saying the same thing.
What Chase is saying is one day of rest,
like go see your aunt, go snowboarding,
go watch Netflix for eight hours,
but not one month, but not one year.
- [Chase] Watch some
great YouTubers, right?
- You see where I'm going Alex?
- Great YouTubers, their
putting content out every day
and they do that for a year
and they're like oh my god,
I'm super crazy, crazy burned out.
They take a couple of days.
I advocate just a little bit here
and there and just keep going.
I'd rather learn how to rest
just a little bit than to quit.
- No, this is exactly,
it's the exact analogy.
- [Chase] Yeah, you're building muscle.
- [Alex] Because you just
come back stronger from it.
- What's that brother?
- [Alex] You just come
back stronger from it.
- Yeah, of course you do and that's like
this is not some weird new
science that I'm preaching.
This is like practical as hell.
That's the thing about creativity,
people, it's like naive, no, no.
It's literally, it's we
are creating machines,
everything in the world,
everything in this room,
all your thoughts, they're all created
and so you might as well
get good at creating.
- [Gary] Chase?
- Yes, sir.
- [Alex] Totally, totally.
- Everything we think, humans
have been around for so long,
everything, we do not
have a singular new idea.
We didn't get lucky
enough to be born first.
Everything just wasn't documented.
A couple people broke through.
- [Alex] Yeah and so that's
why I'm just working on
putting out my content and
I'm getting my podcast started
so I just been putting content out--
- By the way Alex, real quick, real quick,
my favorite word in order,
getting started, makes me smile always.
Post it tomorrow, start it.
- [Alex] Just keep doing it.
- Yeah, just make it.
Everyone's like I'm about
to get my podcast started.
What?
- [Alex] Exactly.
- Dude there's something Anchor,
fucking put it out tomorrow.
- [Alex] Yeah and that's why
I just got all my equipment
and I'm getting my graphics done.
- No, nope.
- Sorry, I gotta call you out
man, I gotta call you out.
- Nope, fuck equipment.
- Do you have a phone, are you
talking on a phone right now?
- [Alex] Yeah.
- [Gary] That's your equipment bro.
- You have all your
equipment right there bro.
- Period, don't be that tennis player
that buys all the best
rackets and all that shit
and then gets smoked by
the guy that comes out
with a wooden racket because
he fucking please tennis.
- [Alex] So I got the kit
that DRock recommended on the site--
- DRock's over here nodding.
- Alex let me tell you why I'm positive
you're not gonna be successful.
You care way too much
about DRock and Babin.
(laughing)
I'm kidding, I'm kidding Alex,
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- Hey, but I also like this is--
- [Alex] I'm just trying to figure out--
- Hey Alex, Alex one second,
sorry to interrupt, sorry
to interrupt you bud.
So I want to talk to you
about something real quick
and it's something I talk
a lot about in the book
because what you're going through,
what you're thinking,
what you're your mindset
right now about I got to get this and that
and all that stuff, that
is a procrastination,
that is avoidance, and
you're avoiding out of fear
because if you actually
start you're gonna see
that your first podcast sucks.
- [Gary] Sucks!
- And then your gonna see that
your second one sucks and so all the---
- And DRock's little fucking kit is
not going to change that.
- [Chase] All this--
- [Alex] That's just the kit
that got me started under--
- Fuck DRock's kit!
- If you say if you say kit
one more time. (laughing)
If you say kit one more time.
- Dude, your phone's your kit, fuck DRock.
- Yeah, hey Alex, let me just
get one crystal-clear idea
across to you and then
everyone can yell at you
on the phone again and that idea is
and I talk about it a lot in the book
that we are obsessed with intellect.
We're obsessed with
thinking things through,
we have journals to write stuff down,
we have kits to buy, we have
shopping list to fulfill,
and you know what, none
of it equals creating.
None of it.
- [Gary] None of it.
- And so you need action my
friend, action over intellect.
Okay?
- [Alex] Yeah and that's
what I'm trying to push
and that's what I'm trying to--
- Alex, Alex, can I ask you a question?
Can I ask you a question?
- [Alex] Yeah.
- On some real shit how
do you deal with feedback?
Is there some nerves
that it won't get enough,
just be real as fuck.
If you wanna win I need
you at your rawest form.
Do you feel like--
- [Alex] No, I do love feedback.
I think failure is the best way.
I feel like people are afraid to tell me
where I suck or they just
kind of try to hesitate
to tell me that I'm not, I'm
doing okay but I'm not sucking.
It's like I need to hear that,
because that's how I learned
from what I'm doing wrong.
That's how I exceed to the next level.
- So why aren't you making
more just on your phone?
What would be your thought?
- [Alex] With my phone I just feel like
I wouldn't be able to
put out quality content.
- Stop, stop, stop, stop.
But if it's subjective,
what you're doing is
you're limiting yourself on
overvaluing production value
and not leaning into the story.
- I'm gonna feed you your own medicine.
You know that talk that
you just referenced,
me and Babin having?
- [Alex] Yeah.
- Made it with my phone.
How's that bro?
- And I got a better one, I made Babin.
(laughing)
- [Alex] That's true, that's 100% true.
- Babin is talented, for
the record Babin made Babin.
- I'm not trying to razz you man.
What I love that you're saying is
that you are in the
particular lies the universal.
You're a story that so
many people tell themselves
and that's why you've been
incredibly helpful on the show
to be vulnerable and say
hey, here's what I believe.
I need all this, I need X, I need Y,
you need action over intellect man,
you need to get started
and this is the number one
thing that keep people from
tapping into their true self,
their true creativity
is that they're worried,
they're all this other stuff.
You just need to start doing it
and you know what when you
start doing it, it's sexy.
I'm going back to sexy.
- [Alex] That's true,
that's how you learn,
and that's how you grow.
- Don't talk, no more talking.
- Don't say kit.
- You're saying everything right,
you're saying everything right.
The far majority of people right now
on the Internet are
saying everything right.
You see where I'm going Alex?
I love how you reacted to
that brother, thank you.
You see where I'm going?
- [Alex] I 100% get it.
- You fundamentally have the words down.
You can regurgitate
everything to me perfectly,
I could taste it from a mile
away, I've been listening.
You've got the words down,
you're just not acting on it.
- [Chase] Action baby.
- [Alex] Yeah, that's 100% Gary
and I 100% believe on that.
I'm gonna just do and stop thinking.
- Yeah and listen, you
know what's cool about
moments like this, why I love doing this?
My hope is here we are,
the three of us, right?
Listening to you talk about DRock, Bab,
and things of that nature, Chase with Bab.
I'm hoping you're like fuck,
all these people that are
putting in their phone numbers,
I got through, you know people sometimes
are looking for that sign.
We all are doing that shit,
all different versions of it.
I'm just desperately
hoping that you decide
this is the sign that you broke through,
that Chase and I you know,
I always laugh, I'm always wondering
what somebody who's never
seen either one of us Chase
are watching this right now and saying,
"Oh, these guys are dicks."
And I'm always like man, we're so doing
the best thing right now.
- [Chase] Trying hard to help.
- We're trying so hard
right now to help this kid.
Just want you to win, like not
trying to make you feel bad,
trying to make you fucking win bro.
- [Chase] Yeah, I bled for
this thing man, this was like--
- [Alex] I 100% get that,
that's what I believe in.
It's just you just gotta do and--
- But you've gotta decide
what the mental unlock is
and that's why it's
either a fear of judgment,
listen, your point of view on quality,
Chase couldn't have said it better.
It's an excuse to not make.
So that's why I go to the next place
after he set up that move,
I'm like okay, let's dance here.
Cool, you have an excuse
to not make, that's firm.
You are not interested in making,
that's firm for everyone who's
listening and for you Alex.
Next, why?
Almost always, almost
always, it's insecurity.
Almost always.
Your dad's gonna say you
should get a real job.
Your girl wants you to get a real job.
You genuinely don't know how
to deal with negative feedback,
because you were over coddled
and you always thought you were great
and then you woke up
at 20 and said oh fuck,
maybe I'm not, I was tricked.
You overvalued school and
really leaned into grades
and became a binary human
that thinks that A and B and C
completely dictates who you are.
There's a million reasons why.
- [Alex] That's 100% and
just gotta go for it so.
- Right, but what I'm most worried about--
- [Alex] And that's where
I'm gonna go from here.
- But what I'm most worried about is
you're now in that middle spot
where the words are the justification.
Even the way your answering here,
like the way you're answering is like
you're in that middle spot
where subconsciously saying it
makes you think you're doing it.
You know how many people in
my community are saying it
or sharing it and that makes them think
they're actually living it?
- [Alex] Well I feel
like I'm trying to do it.
I don't know I just--
- Fuck trying bro, fuck trying bro.
- Remember what Yoda said about trying.
- There is no fucking trying Alex.
- [Alex] Like for real though.
- For real what?
For real what?
- [Alex] Like when you talk
about perspective on life
and you drop that video
on if you can lose someone
and the next day like that happened to me
like I lost my dad overnight
and I think that's kind of like
where my insecurities started
and where my perspective in life changed.
- How old were you brother?
- [Alex] 24.
- Hey, I gotta tell Alex a story.
Alex, right?
- Yes, Alex.
- All right Alex, so
my second grade teacher
told me I was better
at sports then at art,
so I ran to sports and
then I did very well
so she was in a sense right,
but I denied my creativity for a long time
and then not dissimilar to you,
instead of your dad passing away,
my grandpa dropped dead of a heart attack.
I was given his cameras
and it was only when I
was given his cameras
that I had a chance in
just that moment of grief
to look back and say
man, I've been denying
this part of myself for a long time.
And these traumatic moments in life,
they have a profound effect,
use that moment of reflection to decide
what you actually want with your life,
because I'm telling you right now your dad
would want nothing more than for you
to do the thing that you want to be doing.
And that's the number one
regret of the dead and dying,
people who are on their death bed
is that they live the life that
other people wanted for
them, not their own.
- 100 fucking thousand percent.
- Use this as an opportunity
to seize your life,
define the way that you want to live,
and take all the other shoulds,
they're never gonna go away,
there's always gonna be a should.
Do it for you buddy.
- [Gary] Alex, my mom lost her mom at five
and she's the greatest mother of all time.
My dad lost his dad at 15
and he went on the offense to provide.
To be a 24 year old man and
lose a father is devastating.
To be a 24 year old man and lose a father
and then finished the sentence by saying
my intuition right now
and self observation
is that's when my insecurities started
meant that you were relying
on your father too much.
- [Alex] Yeah and I 100% believe that
because he started his own restaurant
and it was all about family
and it just kind of went
downhill from there.
- Yeah, but let this be a great lens man.
- [Gary] Go ahead Alex, keep going.
- [Alex] tat was a big
turning point in my life,
because it was like we had
to go through all his stuff
and that's when I was like wow,
because he was big into
garage saleing and all that.
And so it was just a big moment in my life
where it was like I
really need to figure out
who I am and what I need to do.
- Do you believe that you were
playing within his framework,
that you expected your dad
to keep taking care of you?
You were gonna work in his business,
he was always gonna be
there in tough times?
Like where was your mind at that point?
'Cause that's what it sounds like.
- [Alex] No, I wasn't
working at his business,
like I was doing my
own thing doing H-back,
but he was the one that
kept our family together
and was the one that like bring
us to breakfast on Sundays.
- Yeah, he was the center of it.
- [Alex] Because he started his
own restaurant and all that.
- Look brother, let me say this.
What I think is so amazing
about the world right now
is that the Internet, which
is grossly underrated,
has brought us together at a level
that we've never seen, not even close.
We all know so many more people.
Right now currently in our society
we're spending a lot of time
looking at the negatives.
That's the current vibe.
When Chase and I were doing social
back in the day it was Nirvana.
Yeah, it was a kumbaya,
it was hippie shit.
Now it's cliche, humans
do this with everything.
Right now we're in the part
where we're over scrutinizing,
over judging each other,
everyone's pointing fingers,
we're pulling each other apart.
However this moment right
now as you're talking,
this is what I live for.
The humanity capabilities
that we have by having these,
where are you again?
- [Chase] Physically.
- [Alex] Spokane, Washington.
- Right, like think about
what we're doing right now.
Thousands of people are watching us online
from all over the world,
you're in Spokane,
we're sitting here, we're talking.
Like brother you have your
whole life in front of you.
- [Alex] Yeah and I feel
like a 100% grateful
for the positivity that
you guys put out there
and that's what's always
helped change my mindset.
- So do us the greatest
favor you could ever,
which is take that and start doing things
because the word, nothing
feels better to me
than when somebody stops
me and takes a selfie
or writes me a manifesto,
but I always leave thinking
I hope they're doing it.
If nobody ever said
another nice thing to me,
a accolade, a stopping me,
you know some people are
very kind of like chill,
a wink, that's an acknowledgment,
which I value just as much as a selfie.
If nobody ever did that
again, yet they all did,
I would be 4,000 times happier.
I just want you to do bro,
like everybody's got
adversities you know that
and I just believe in your like--
- [Chase] You can feel it man.
- You're just such a good
kid, man you got this.
You fucking got this bro.
You're gonna live three more full lives
and let me give you a news alert.
You're gonna have bigger tragedies
than what you're going through right now.
- [Alex] Yeah and I believe that
and that's why I'm just
grateful for the years
that I had with my dad and all that
so I just gotta keep pushing.
- 100% and you've got to do it
for yourself and your future life.
- Know that the answers are in you man.
You have all of the information you need.
It's all right there.
- [Alex] Yeah, 100% so thank
for letting me ask my question.
- Respect man.
- Alex, before you go,
do we have a prayer of you making a video
and putting it out tomorrow?
Tell me the truth.
- [Alex] For my podcast?
- [Chase] No, no, no.
- Sure.
- [Chase] Anything.
- Will you put out something
and let me ask you question, go ahead.
- [Alex] No, I put out something
every day on my Instagram
and I work on Facebook and all that, yeah.
- And what do you what do you
want to happen in the end,
I'm sorry I'm standing on
this Chase, I'm just into it.
- [Alex] I'm just trying
to build the community
around Spokane and all
the local businesses,
because I think there's a
lot of potential over here
so that's what I'm just
trying to work towards.
- Hey, I'm gonna ask a favor.
Let Gary and I each
give you a prescription.
This is like doctors moment here, okay?
So G you want to tell him
one thing he should do
and then I'll give him something.
- Punch Babin in the face.
(Chase laughing)
You go first, you go first.
I'm reading the comments.
- So my ask for you is this.
If you made a video as
soon as you hang up,
you turn your phone and pointed it at you,
and you told the story
of what just happened
about you got in on the call-in show,
started talking about this book,
and you shared with your
community the real shit
you're going through and you put that out,
because it's gonna look a lot different
than all your other
Instagram stuff, right?
- Alex, what's your Instagram
while Chase is talking?
- [Alex] AmazingA23.
- AmazingA23.
- Can I ask you a quick
question, it's very important.
Please tell me 23 isn't
because of Michael Jordan,
but don't lie, tell me the truth.
- [Alex] It's 100%
because of Michael Jordan.
(Chase laughing)
Not gonna lie.
- [Chase] Okay, it's fine,
it's fine, but just take--
- It really isn't fucking fine Chase.
It can be fine on your fucking platform,
it's not fucking fine
on the #AskGaryVee Show.
It took everything for me not to hang up
and I was right there.
I'm trying to evolve too but fuck bro!
You're in Washington.
Shawn Kemp, Gary Payton bro.
Kevin Durant if they
moved, fucking Jordan!
- It does sting a little
bit, I'm not gonna lie,
- [Alex] Jordan, he changed basketball--
- He didn't change shit!
- [Alex] He did.
- He fucking sucks.
- Hey Alex, do me a favor
and make that video bud.
Turn the phone to
yourself, make that video,
and post it and I bet, I bet--
- Did he say amazing Alex 23?
- AmazingA23.
(people speaking off mic)
All right, that's my prescription.
- [Man] Oh, what's up Alex?
- [Man] You know Alex.
- [Alex] Thank you.
- Yeah, everyone here knows you.
- [Alex] I'll take that advice 100%.
- Great, give it a shot and be real.
Say we got to talking
about my dad and it hurts
and I realized that I'm living
in his shoes a little bit
and I need to break out, whatever
is true for you, say that.
- [Alex] All right thank
you, I'll take that advice.
- Okay, now here's my advice.
- [Chase] Oh god, here we go.
- First of all, I'm going to
follow you back AmazingA23.
As a matter of fact, everybody
who's watching and listening
please go following follow AmazingA23
right now on Instagram.
He's at 404, I'm sure we can get to 4,000.
- [Alex] Thanks Gary, you
didn't have to do that.
- You're welcome, what's that?
- [DRock] 413.
- Alright DRock, calm down.
(everyone laughing)
DRock, we just had a manifesto
of not putting metrics
on a pedestal and you're
like jumping up and down
for nine more followers.
I was establishing
contacts, you jumped around
like it was fucking
Christmas for nine followers.
AmazingA, I need you to go back tonight
and right before we go to
sleep give a lot of thought
to why you think you love Michael Jordan
and I'm gonna explain why
and I'm not fucking kidding.
I think there's a lot of
insight to that stuff.
I believe there's a lot of insight
to people following LeBron
or being Golden State fans
or being a fan of Tom Brady
when you live in Houston
and should be a Texans fan.
I believe there's a fascinating
underlining thing going on in the world.
As a matter of fact,
you putting out photos
with my sneakers on like on your account.
You can't arrive on your own self-esteem
from other people's success.
- [Alex] Yeah, 100%.
- It's safe, you're playing it safe man
and it's understandable
because you've been told
to play it safe you said
you're supposed to do this
and that and all the
instructions we get in life.
- Your Dad, Michael Jordan, me.
I'm telling you right now.
You see where I'm going brother?
- [Alex] I'm gonna sit back tonight
and think about all that 'cause
that's what I need to do.
- I want you take my Clouds
and Dirt Limited Edition
dark skies that you're
wearing in your photos
and I want you to put them on eBay
and I want you to sell them.
- [Alex] 100%, I'll do that right now.
- I want you to then DM me the link.
[Alex] Okay, I will.
- Okay, that's my call to action.
[Alex] All right.
- I love you brother, take care bro.
[Alex] Thanks Gary, I appreciate you guys.
- All right, take care bro.
Chase?
- [Chase] Yeah man.
- Listen that was one of the great things.
Caleb's fucking crying.
I'm in a very simple place.
If you're listening or watching right now
order three copies of Creative Calling,
give them to two people you love.
I really, really want
Chase to do well here,
because listen, I think
everybody understands.
The economics and book
deals or sneaker deals
or wine deals are not the variable,
it is the competitive
spirit of him wanting to,
you know, when I call
next week and be like bro,
I sold 10 times more
than you the first week,
he's a warrior, he's
trying to win out there.
So I want to hedge that so
it's only half as many as I did
so order three copies, hook 'em up.
- Instead of 10, right, it's three.
- Hook him up, Chase thanks
for being on the show.
- I really appreciate
you, thanks a lot man.
Love you and love your community.
- Thank you I'm gonna
say a couple shout outs
on the way out here for
the people in the community
on Facebook we've been watching.
Mike McDonald, what's up?
Beverly Sankey, what's good?
JB Fellotuber, I love
you, thanks for listening.
Robert Crowe, thank you.
Nancy Summers, you had some
great comments by the way Nance.
John Muhammad Almarahzook I love you.
Tim Gallonback, I love you.